à paris cette manifestation aujourd'hui
place de la bastille de la communauté
algérienne qui appelle à la libération
immédiate du journaliste khaled drr eni
en raison de son état de santé
les manifestants qui demandent également
le respect de toutes les libertés
démocratiques de presse de
manifestations et d'organisation on va
en parler tout de suite avec notre
reporter sur place nadège ad razak
bonsoir nadège vous suivez cette
manifestation place de la république
quelle est l'ambiance autour de vous
mais écoutez magali à cette
manifestation se déroule dans le calme
et la bonne humeur manifestation qui est
parti en début d'après midi depuis la
place de la république et qui a atteint
sa destination en fin de journée on et
place de la bastille
quelques milliers de personnes ont
participé à ce rassemblement aujourd'hui
vous l'avait dit pour demander la
libération du journaliste khaled drame
ni incarcéré depuis plusieurs mois
alger il a été arrêté à la fin du mois
de mars après avoir couvert une
manifestation du est là quand ce
mouvement de contestation inédit qui a
secoué l'algérie pendant plus d'un an
plus d'un an donc voilà des soutiens qui
exigent sa libération a à deux jours
maintenant de son procès en appel
en première instance khaled adrar ni un
ce correspondant de tv5monde de
reporters sans frontières a été condamné
à une peine de trois ans de prison pour
incitation attroupement et atteinte à
l'unité nationale vous l'avez dit sa
santé sa situation elle s'est dégradée
alors il est plus qu'urgent ans d'après
ses nombreux soutiens de le libérer
parmi ses soutiens figure eliès est jay
bybee il est un militant du collectif
algérie droit devant nous bonjour merci
d'être là leur dites moi pourquoi est ce
qu'il est urgent de libérer alors khaled
rare ni selon vous et quelle est sa
situation actuellement merci de m'avoir
donné la parole aux fêtes
voilà il faut libérer il faut libérer le
journaliste khaled rallye qui subit la
pression quitte à la prison une prise en
fait en train de subir une pression
totalitaire une pression énorme il est
dans un état sanitaire préoccupant donc
il est urgent de lui libéré il est
victime de l'arbitraire victime d'une
justice de téléphone victime de la junte
militaire victimes parce qu'il pense
qu'il a voulu faire son travail de façon
équitable est victime de cette de cette
jeune militaire qui fait le pli le beau
temps en algérie
voilà il est victime voilà les jeunes
aussi nous dénonçons je dénonçais nous
dénonçons toutes les détentions
arbitraires et l'emprisonnement du
journaliste guidage nova et demi de
aussi de la chine les caisses et tous
les détenus d'opinion qui croupissent
dans les prisons de façon injuste ils
sont emprisonnés de façon injuste s'il
subissent l'arbitraire l'impétrant de
dune 2 sec aussi généraux qui font la
pluie le beau temps
c'est une situation intenable nous a
coûté mois à l'algérie a été secoué
pendant plus d'un an par des
manifestations monstres
est ce que vous me dites c'est que la
situation l'algérie elle a empiré après
la blague la situation la situation en
algérie elles sont pires de jour en jour
elles sont pires avec le temps nos
revendications sont des revendications
politiques
nous voulons un changement des systèmes
de gouvernance nous voulons un
changement radical ne voulons pas la
militarisation de la delà de la poly
delà de la politique en algérie
li militaires doivent restituer la
souveraineté au peuple en activant
l'article 7 et 8
certes l'algérie est un pays indépendant
nous sommes indépendants depuis 62 nous
avons chassé le colonel français mais
nous subissons le néocolonialisme de
notre de nos propres de nos propres
concitoyens de nos propres construire
ses généraux là qui gère l'algérie et
qui confie ce que la souveraineté
merci beaucoup à lies et djebaïli je
rappelle que vous êtes un militant du
collectif droit devant nous merci donc
vous l'avez entendu magali un beau coup
de colère et d'amertume auprès de
beaucoup de ces manifestants qui
réclament donc à la libération immédiate
de
allez aidera nini et qui déplore donc
cette dégradation de l'état l'état
politique en algérie
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions nadège abderrazak en direct
de la place de la bastille à paris